so what we'll do here and we've changed
some things around you will notice that
some things have changed uh not so long
ago we have moved the metagenomics
section right here and what we will do
today is we will just take a look at
this last example called amplicon16s
so if you click on this dropdown
you will
open this
section right here
and this is called
the data2 pipeline so you will find
right here in the middle a section
called data2
now we're not going to go into a lot of
detail about this what i want you to see
today is just how to run a demo pipeline
what are the inputs and outputs and what
does it mean where do you go from there
so here you want to click on start
you can see what we cover today kind of
what is being sequenced the data 2
pipeline is specifically designed for
pair and metagenomic sequencing data for
amplicon-16s ribosomal rna
so here the 16s ribosomal rna
hypervariable regions are being
sequenced not the full gene
and then one of the objectives of this
pipeline is to actually denoise the
actual sequences so the more precise the
sequences that we have the better we
will be able to match them accurately to
the reference database and then if we
have an accurate match we can then also
analyze differences in composition or
maybe
how they are related to each other
phylogenetically
so here an important step
is to understand the challenge right and
and one of the challenges is with this
great diversity of microorganisms that
we are studying that we are sequencing
there is expected to be a lot of
variation and because of that variation
it's important for us to differentiate
between
technical variation like noise and data
coming as a result of inaccurate
sequencing
maybe because we don't have a lot of
good coverage or maybe because
um you know there is a lot of diversity
how do we actually understand the
biological diversity that we have we
have to denoise and uh kind of eliminate
the mistakes and to do that
we need to uh merge the pair end reads
and then combine them into what's called
operational taxonomic units that allows
us to eliminate a lot of the variability
that is inconsistent unfortunately it
also reduces a lot of the reads
um that we will have but we are only
going to be keeping um reads that are
accurate um and and could be matched to
something
so once we do this i'm going to quickly
go through
some of these
some of these steps we want to assign
those to the right reference in this
database
and assigning them
means that now i cannot just speak about
individual otus operational taxonomic
units but i can group them
by whatever level of taxonomy i was able
to annotate them by
and
you know one of the challenges is going
to be the lower we want to go on the
taxonomy scale
the less information we might be able to
get
because of these hyper variable regions
and their variation but also because of
the coverage and how precise we know
which one came from there now from this
point on
we essentially have several different
tables those tables include a table of
otu
abundance or how
much of a particular operational
taxonomic unit i have proportionately in
each sample
and the annotation of where does that
otu mapped to from the reference
database
because i have the reference database i
also know the relationship between them
how close are they to each other could
they be grouped in some way how far away
are they evolutionary from each other
and then i can download i can do perform
downstream analysis which includes uh
building that phylogenetic relationship
with ape and then visualizing the
results with phyloseq which is a package
in r
that allows us to make visualizations
and all kinds of statistical analysis
that then we can interpret in terms of
differences between groups of samples or
looking at individual samples
so once we do that and we click on end
right here
we will look at some of the output files
so once you click on ok
right here you will have a folder called
download pipeline output files
okay how many of you
were able to get to
this last
screen that i have
okay perfect
rafael did anyone else
okay if you did not
again i'll just repeat the steps really
quickly so from areas of analysis
down here amplicon 16s 18s you click on
this drop down
go into the demo
start
qc filtering
replication accounts
pair merge
cluster consensus otu
remove chimera
assign taxonomy
ape
and then philosophy
so after this you click on end
and you get the download pipeline output
files
open this up and now you have several
different things and these are the kinds
of results that you're going to be
getting from a pipeline these results
will include
tables txt files for example
plots like these pdaf plots right here
faster files of actual sequences and
those are the major types of data that
you will have to deal with
okay so as an example right
this is going to be explained in much
greater detail
in the course
so when you go into the meta genomics
course
and you want to understand what was it
that we were doing
right here you have
a practical sixteen s marriage genomic
analysis lesson that you can review
understand each one of the steps and see
all of the results in one place but
before you jump in there
you want to go through all of these
different sections to understand what
kinds of sequencing data do we have
what are the specific ways to analyze
them and then even practice some of the
basics so that you understand what is
going to be in an individual sample file
and to do that let us take a look at
another example so let's go
uh now hopefully everybody has a good
sense of what we can do on the platform
just what kinds of things we're going to
be doing
and here we're going to be doing
something else here we're going to try
and run a piece of code in r and at the
end of this session you can download
this code and run it on your system as
well
so what i will do is i will go into this
lesson six
okay this is the link
and we'll just go through this lesson
with a little exercise at the end
okay so please let me know once you're
on this link we're going to take just a
few minutes it's not going to be a long
time
all right perfect
so here we have a different problem
there we had multiple samples and the
question was
how do these groups of samples compare
to each other
in this case we will just take one
sample so we don't have anything to
compare to we just want to understand
what's in it
and to do that we will use a different
pipeline so this is a pipeline that is
going to do something very different
here we will take full 16s ribosomal rna
gene that is a sequence
we are going to align it to a reference
database of all 16s ribosomal rna genes
we're going to count how many do we have
of what kind
and we're going to annotate them
okay and so here
the basic table that we're going to be
dealing with looks like this
you have individual elements genomic
elements
for example 16s ribosomal rna
and you can see how the kingdom phyla
etc is organized according to the
different taxonomic classification
with
how many of each kind do i have
and then you will also be able to
annotate
right so separate them
and see
how many do you have of different types
of for example phyla
right so if we just focus on phyla
we can see how many of each kind do we
have now they will come up many times
right because multiple organisms fall
under different phyla so we need to
combine them together
so after we combine them together we can
calculate percentages uh what's the
percentage of a particular type from the
total that we have
and obviously we can visualize such data
right we can prepare some kind of a
visual representation
and that is sometimes more informative
we can do a pie chart
or we can do a bar plot so essentially
we can see
what is happening with our data and so
this lesson is to be able to do these
simple steps in r
if you already know r
you know that for many different
applications in r there's typically a
library that already contains many of
the functions that you would like to use
so you don't actually have to reinvent
the wheel
some of these packages are very specific
like filoseq they just produced a set
number of plots that are useful for a
particular application like for example
phylogenetic analysis for filocyg
but some of them are more general
libraries and those libraries include
ways to visualize data and create
different plots or maybe calculate
different statistics for different types
of things that you can find
so here we'll do something very simple
we'll
learn how to load our data prepare a pie
chart and then we'll make a bar plot
because bar plot could actually be
more easy to interpret visually than a
pie chart
so
the objective would be just to
understand
how many of each kind do i have in a
particular single sample without
having to compare to anything so here we
have some code
and let's just go through this code
really quickly
we load in library
this library is to load an excel file
now sometimes you will have csv files
txt files
excel files so you need to be able to
load those data and load them into your
environment into your script here we'll
do it right here on our server but
you can also do it in r
so
then we want to sort
the data
and sorting the data is useful because
instead of looking at
images that look like this
we can kind of organize them to all look
like this from highest to lowest
and once we do that we then uh create
percentages
um
make a pie chart and also make a bar
plot at the end
so let's see how difficult is it for us
to perform all of these steps including
adding some color here as well
okay so here you have
a a console which is where you run the
code
and in this console you already have all
of the data and all of the script loaded
in
in fact if you want to use this data set
on your computer you might want to
download it right here so just right
click on this link
and download linked file
if you want to see what happens when you
run this code this code should run in
exactly the same way on your computer as
it does here the only thing that you
need to remember is that we're using a
library
yes you can run it on rstudio
but in our studio you will need to have
the only library that we're using is
this additional library excel
to read excel files
okay so let's try to run it
and you can see that first of all
we have a success right we we correctly
have the answer
and right here we have the results so
this is
a pie chart that we created and this is
a bar plot that we created and this bar
plot is already annotated
now let's try
how to change just one little thing so
that we know that this is actual code
that runs and not just
you know an automatic button
so one of the things that you can see
here
is that when we create a pie chart or a
bar plot
we actually call give them a title main
is a title
and here we also make
different dimensions for our plots so
we're going to do two things we're going
to increase the dimensions because this
is kind of small
and we're actually going to change the
title
okay so here we're going to
change this to pie chart
and here we're going to add bar plot
and you can try to do this in r studio
as well
okay
so here you can see that we also
add
uh
the label to our x-axis
and so when we look at the x-axis right
here in the bar plot you can see
bacteria type
okay but actually the type
is
by a phylum right so
here we want to add
okay
now
once we do this oh yeah we also wanted
to increase
um
the size
so let's do like this
and let's run it again
okay so here
pie chart right we change that
and here we also changed phylum and bar
plot right here and i noticed by the way
that i capitalized the c so we can make
it smaller
so this is an actual piece of code if i
want to take it to my computer what do i
need to do copy right here's the copy
code button
open our studio
if anyone doesn't have our studio we
have a little tutorial on how to install
our studio
and then you can run the exact same code
obviously you would need to set up your
environment to have the library
and to have the file okay so here's our
studio
let's make it bigger
create a new script
paste it here
okay and here right we have this library
i already have it installed
let's run it
okay object labels is not found
so right here we have
so i think
what is happening let's run it like this
okay
like this
and run it like this
all right and so there we have it it
also works
in our studio
okay
so to summarize because we're already
going over time
let's
wrap this up and summarize what we have
done today
the objective of this program is to
provide us with
methods of analysis that we know how to
perform and we know how to interpret
today we ran a demo pipeline called the
data two pipeline and we saw this data
two pipeline in terms of the inputs and
the outputs kind of understanding the
logic of analysis
now there are many other types of
analysis that we can do and we looked at
this annotation
of 16s right with stoma rna
we have the kind 2 pipeliners as well
and we have this data 2 pipeline so we
can look at those different examples and
how they approach the same problem with
different other methods we also looked
at this simple example of
visualization how can we visualize the
data that we have from sequencing
and
we saw that we have this abundance of
proteobacteria in this particular sample
now what do you do
moving forward
so i recommend
several different publications
that you can
go through
to kind of get started uh moving further
into
um
this field of metagenomics
there's a good review of the human
microbiome project which contains a lot
of 16s ribosomal rna data used in a
variety of studies
you will also find here in a paper i'll
share the links in just a moment
bioinformatics for micro myo research
concept strategies and advances
and also explore the actual human
microbiome projects as well so these are
this is a collection of data
that has
16s as well as metagenomics
as well
and you can see different types of
collections within this
project so let me get you
these links real quick
okay so here are those links
okay now moving forward inside the
actual uh tutorials
you will find these different additional
resources an overview of sequencing
methods of analysis
different project examples including
some exercises that you can do and then
hopefully after you complete that kind
of training you will be able to uh apply
this to a data set of your own so we do
have a whole project where you can
go through several lessons on how to
develop an independent research project
including where to find data how to plan
for your analysis and if you need help
how to submit it to some of our mentors
to give you advice
and direction on how to develop an
independent research project with omix
data and bioinformatics